hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to suite
776. press one to play
[Music]
okay all right quite an intro please
keep in mind that suite 776 contains
flashing lights also heavily aggressive
with horror elements keep this in mind
and progress at your own discretion now
this game when i found it
it had a 100 rating everyone was saying
that this game was
incredible estimated single play through
time 50 minutes estimate does not
include multiple endings or all
achievements
it's oh it does not contain oh it
doesn't save okay
all right good to know marcy was found
in her home dead she hung herself she
left her only family alone her
seven-year-old son marcy was a famous
architect a very well-known architect
unfortunately she became too well known
for the wrong reasons it is my intention
to prove that sweet 776 exists to that i
will photograph marcy in motion i will
photograph her even if it kills me no
matter what that that's
that what
all that is left to do is ring her bell
that's all it takes just ring
the bell
wait a minute
oh
i'm in a vader
okay so all i got to do is ring her bell
and i'm gonna get this picture whether
it kills me
that doesn't seem a little extreme to
you
that doesn't seem a little bit crazy
oh hi whoa
okay
loud chime very good seven seven three
seven seven four
[Music]
oh
seven seven two seven seven five well
that's
odd numbering system
seven seven one and seven seven six
i don't see no bell
maybe the bell was the vader
all right hey marcy
hey marcy
marcy how you doing
marcy
hey oh
just got some pt vibes out of this i
survived sweet 776. it is real it all
appeared real but that couldn't be
possible i was on the 12th floor yet
looking through the windows displayed
the first floor there are over six other
suites on this floor yet suite 776
appeared larger with impossible
proportions there was even an upper and
a lower level of the suite it made no
sense whatsoever and how did i get out
why am i the only one i have no clue i
came to sweet 776 with the intention of
recording my journey i set up cameras
but all the footage was lost well that's
awfully convenient xx gamer xx
unfortunately for you i'm here now and
i'm gonna get this evidence ten
ten
ooh
lock and weak and simple and i'm strong
and complex all right
whoa
where would that door go wait a minute
wait wait a minute
the outside doesn't seem quite right
here
something seems a little off
wait
wait this this hallway shouldn't loop
like this
no
no no no no no
oh the bell i've heard so much about you
oh i'm such a fan
ah door's locked everything's awfully
clunky in this apartment sorry
sweet
dang the bell has been wrung
all right i did it i'm sure i'm glad
that i did it
of all the things that i've ever done in
my life that is the one that i am most
glad about
thunk
all right
well goody goody gumdrops
if this isn't just the light of my life
what a wait a minute
wasn't there a door here
was there oh no there wasn't wait what
maybe i should try ringing the bell one
more time baby
why would that thought says no you just
needed to bring it once and then i got
to get out of here so i'm gonna go
bye marcy even if it kills me i'm gonna
get out through this
probably not gonna do anything for me
huh
all right
goodbye
well i guess that was a fun experience i
sure learned a lot about myself and my
tolerance for the supernatural which is
none oh [ __ ]
[Music]
i got an ending
sometimes it's best to leave myths
behind treat them as though they don't
exist wise words my friend no matter how
badly i want to accept that i can't i
just have so many questions with no
answer not wise words my friend there is
a way to save my mother i know there is
but what could it be wait a minute there
has to be a pattern of some sort of
sequence of some sort that must be
commenced
whey but i
wait but i my
oh what what could that sequence be i'll
have to come back one day and find out
but that wait my own mother that means
i'm the kid that marcy left behind finn
okay wait a minute wait i didn't expect
that to work you never know in games
like this if you could just walk away
which is the smart thing to game stats
what game stats
what is the mercy in motion taking i
didn't even know i had a camera
easter egg
view credits
no i don't get no stop stop stop you're
so slow oh why are you so slow speed it
up
the bell
has been wrung
the gauntlet
has been thrown down
and now
i'm hoping that something
is gonna happen
oh
maybe i should try ringing the bell one
more time
maybe you're right
maybe you might have an inkling is there
that many trees before
was i able to see that clearly out
though i don't remember
oh
was that always there before
wait a minute what's that over there is
that a boyd
i don't know about i don't know about
that one chief
all right boy sure is getting choir of
the damned up in here
ring-a-ling-a-ding-dong
the bell has been wrung a second time
all right i did it i showed marshy who's
the boss
and it's me
marcy
or should i say
mother
i i don't remember there being a second
floor
i don't remember there definitely was
not
a second floor
definitely
[Music]
you don't get to do such simple things
as close a door in my face
oh so now
you're not locked in here with me
i'm locked in here with you
i see how it is marcy
if that is your real name i'm gonna ring
your bell again marcy
i'm gonna ring it and there's
never mind you beat me to it i
legitimately
wait a minute hey who's who's who's
ringing the bell over here hey who who's
ringing the bell who who rings bells
bella's been running a fourth time
okay
all right okay
okay yeah
yeah
whatever
um
she's above me
you're right up there no
what
huh
oh my god perhaps he was a genius just
nobody realized that yeah maybe oh yeah
that yeah maybe yeah
that seems believable uh-huh
sweetheart
did i die did i die is that a death or
what did i do
oh i haven't even gotten started
i'm just getting warmed up
okay good
great
i'm not oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
press and hold left click for night
vision press right click to snap a photo
of a moving target
okay
okay i'd access your inventory huh the
first page of my notebook is missing
something actually poured it out i awoke
in suite 776 or so i think i did i feel
as though i have been fully locked in it
actually feels like an illusion like
it's not real
yeah yeah none of this seems really real
to me
okay uh obligatory gonna check the front
door
nah you know
i thought i could pull a fast one on you
but it turns out you were way ahead of
me
man
this is kind of spooky
this is kind of spoken
was that lightning
was that lightning hey you don't trick
me twice mr lamp i'ma go around you
what is with the what is with the fish
hook
what's the fish recall about
is that something important mars
it's dark over there
marcy
oh i did not mean to do that
i did i did not mean to do that am i
supposed to be ready at any moment to
take a picture of something moving
you are joking
if you think i'ma go in there
all right i'm gonna go in there
okay i'm going in there all right easy
that was nothing
like it weren't nothing
bing-bong
i can't ding-dong the bing-bong
okay
all right
i'll take your word on that
buddy
i got a key now
what do i do with key
do i put it on fish hook
fish is blue
whoa
oh yeah i thought it was blue old key
with an inscription office
right
i know what the office is
i
definitely why is my inventory so gosh
darn
intense
okay
so that's locked do i do anything
do i
hover over an item for more no i i'm
guessing that if i just wang doodle on
it it'll open
right
oh there's something up there
what is that
oh that
is unexpected
was not locked ring the bell again oh
you know i'm
i thought i saw something
red
locked red box with three inserts above
interesting
ah yes i love the sims as well
all right marcy does not appear to be in
the proper state of mind several tests
were conducted testing our reactions to
stressful environmental conditions
reaction marcy displayed include
twitching mumbly readiness excessive
laughter mercy decided to end the
session early unfortunately i advise you
consult marcy to return for another
assessment medication may be required as
currently the way i see it mercy may
endanger herself or others would you
mind forwarding over the context of
marcel's family perhaps her son thank
you dr stan t
dr satan more like it
oh was not locked really
i get to go upstairs now
i go
i don't get to go upstairs now i keep
thinking and you keep tricking me game
i keep thinking and
apparently i'm wrong
all of the time hey whoa is that a
security camera
weird
okay so i gotta ring the bell again or
at least that's what i've been
instructed to do
and i'm a good boy i'm gonna go ring the
bell i'm doing what i as i was told
i'm doing as i was as told
ringing the bell again
bell has been wrung a fifth time
[Music]
all right
so what about that
so what does that mean
well that's convenient i don't have to
find a key for that door
or frankly to be perfectly honest i
didn't want to go in there anyway
marcy
two three ready for
creeping me
i am
marcy
you in there marcy
one two
oh god oh god
all right
open up marcy
open up
oh my god i just is my door behind me
open
oh
oh god my door behind me is open isn't
it oh
how's it been open this whole time or
did it just open
oh my god oh my god i gotta close it i
have to claw i have to climb marcy
no marcy jargi winner
martian
marcy
okay
definitely no one in there
definitely
i
i closed it
like
i closed that
i closed that door okay anyway
so what what did i miss what did i miss
hey what did i miss hey marcy how you
doing
this game is terrifying
can i leave yet
or do i gotta go ring-a-ling ling the
bell
i think i gotta go ring-a-ling ding the
okay
good good you know it's fine
i keep thinking i see things out of the
corner of my eye but that can't possibly
be right
must be just my mind playing tricks on
me
okay
sixth time baby
yeah
so what
i'm a badass
that's how i do
that's what i do just because i use
night vision
doesn't mean i ain't afraid
yeah that's what i thought marcy yeah
i'm coming for you huh
look at this
photograph sure is funny
all right
interviewer you mentioned that marcy had
a bell on her desk at the office would
you mind repeating what you told me
prior to this interview co-worker well
every time she would read something
online about herself or her work that
she didn't agree with she would ring
that bell the bell rang continuously
especially after she finished the
construction of her new home her
masterpiece as she called it she was an
angry person wasn't she
maybe i don't know
i can't speak to that
a fridge lock that's not normal but okay
all right
sure oh what is this
a hairpin
oh
a cork bulletin board seems like it's
missing whatever was displayed here well
i guess i'll fix it
because that's how i do
what
there's a force keeping it shut
off
there's a force
keeping it shut
up close she looks torn unaware of
herself oh that's right i asked did i
snap a picture of her
oh god i've always read tales when i was
younger on demonic possession you're
aware of everything even as your own
blood begins flooding your eyes you just
couldn't move a muscle but he could
could marcy be possessed
okay
all right so i've got
a bobby pin
so that must mean
there might be a door
that i could open
maybe to go up the stairs
that's a weird sound for a fan
hello
bobby pin
okay
oh oh oh
oh ring it again remind me
ring it again remind me of my failures
ah yes great i'll do that
let me add them
let me add them buster brown but first
let me go try to i don't know why the
screwdriver would help with the door up
here but i'm just you know i'm just
gonna try
all right still locked i'm gonna ring it
again
i'm gonna do as i'm told i'm gonna ring
ring a ding ding dong
remind me of my failed dead oh i will
grab you from behind watch me
[Music]
so door's still close okay door's still
closed okay good okay good good good
dead huh
dad you say interesting very interesting
very interesting this is all very
interesting
very very interesting
[Music]
ring
yeah i'll do it i'm gonna do it i'm
doing it
or
okay
the bell has been rung a seventh time
hey do you remember that time
you were competing in the
architect olympics and you just couldn't
get your right angles correct
oh
you're gonna grab me from behind i need
to watch you
that's how it goes that's how it go
that's what you said you warned me come
upstairs okay
hello
hi oh these are fun mannequins by the
way
oh ho what oh come back
marcy
oh [ __ ] marcy marcy
[Music]
marcy you scared
marcy you scamp
you scamp
[Music]
marcy
come on now
you're being ridiculous
oh
boss how you how you how you how you
doing okay all right
stop being
ridiculous marcy marcy
marcy
marcy do not enter
you're not my real mom
strange door with a strong lock securing
it okay
whoever you say
oh
i'll take that
was already unlocked you say
oh
yeah this
oh yeah this oh interior live
what what do i what do i what do i what
do i do
i'm trying is taking many pictures i
can't i can't anymore
okay
continue it guys
oh wait what what what
where are we
how do i get out of this
how do i get out of the camera
i don't know how to get out of the
camera
how do
oh
i'm just looking hey is that the room
i'm in wait a minute that's the room i'm
in isn't it hey wait wait a minute lady
marcie you by the way you're tall
you're real tall you're real tall
real tall lady
marcy
well that doesn't sound good
all right that's what i would call not
good oh that's not good
all right it's not good
okay marsha i'm coming for you i want to
hear you there rj please
long string
long string from the long lady
designer of the decade
huh all right
oh eight three six two
the mini the fridge code is in the mini
fridge eight three six two
yeah
a dangling hook i might find that useful
but how will i reach it it's far too far
out and too high up
how about my string
very useful when used with other items
she's literally stalking me right now
trying to prepare myself for when she
grabs me from behind any moment
what you can't just say
oh god
i don't know if you can tell the door's
open like a crack i don't
sorry
i just
you can't it's
okay
we're good
i don't think i closed it all the way
we're good that's fine that's normal
it's
okay that's normal i guess i just didn't
close it all the way and i'm gonna go
with that because the alternative is
terrifying so i'm gonna reject that
reality and substitute my own eight
three six two good good numbers
good numbers oh a shower you say i could
use that
okay well that was good
i have a string but i need something to
attach it to so i can remove what's in
the drain it looks like i'm gonna need a
hook eventually but i don't have one now
oh wait what
wait where did where would those stairs
go wait wait wait wait wait a minute
what oh a ladder
i'll just put that in my pocket
door's locked you see
i
don't agree
so where the hell would this go
where the hell is this
oh
okay hang on i need to open oh that's
interesting
look at this photograph
maybe it's photography of all of her
architectures
okay i got four of six great
i am doing a 8362.
also there's various clocks
interesting
wait a minute
this one's at seven
nine three seven
those are the numbers that i've seen so
far and they're color coordinated oh but
this is probably
eight
three six two
two
perfect you're behind me very nippy
oh
okay
handy
you want me to ring the bell again
i could ring the bell again can i put
the stepladder here
can i put that oh wait a minute
aha
just go up
small hook
okay
great
i'm gonna go upstairs and reach into the
drain
because that's a normal thing for me to
do at this juncture
gee i wonder when she's gonna reach
behind and grab me
from behind
all right great good all right
picked up a golden key ah
a golden key you say well i'm not sure
what that's for but i've got that now
so that's good
that's very good
oh
all right
interviewer many have found that you
constantly purchase those clothing
mannequins what are those mannequins for
well you know i figured it would be
interesting to have a headcount of those
who opposed me you know wake up in the
morning look at their physical
representation straight in the face i
would scream at them to back off but
they just stand there looking at me it
drives me crazy
right
right good
ah gold bar good
ring ring ring ring it again remind me
of my failures sure
ah
ring
whatever the hell that is pinball
machine
hanging
um
three oh three gold bars
okay
interesting
oh oh
oh
mercy
marcy i didn't know you were there
so funny mercy that i didn't know you
where is he
i don't think i want to do that i want
it i'm in i'm down for it i'm down i
don't think i want it i'm down come on
marcy marcy
marzie
[Music]
marzie come on
all right i guess i gotta go wait so
there's a diagram here i need three gold
bars i've got one gold bar i don't know
where the other gold bars are
okay and there's the last uh
that one's at one so we've had nine
three seven and one maybe it's another
code for the fridge and if you put that
in a different thing would be in there
nine seven three one yeah
all right
interesting planks covering the door i
wonder what's inside you know i don't
care that much
oh i could bolt cutter this
i shouldn't go in here
i'm gonna go in here still locked how do
i open it god if i this is this is so
ridiculous this is insanity okay what if
there's a if i get
okay a bar it fits good good no
i just gotta find more gold bars
you know how it is okay cool all right
we gucci let's do this
let's do this
when are you gonna sneak up behind me
marcy
when are you gonna do it
when you're gonna do it ah you're locked
aren't you
eighth time baby
big old number eight
okay it's dark it's really dark
okay it's dork
all right
eighth time baby
face time baby
all right what did that do
marcy
are you up in the shower again
okay
well this is confusing
marcy
yoo-hoo
oh
you're not marcy
you're not marcy at all
what are you doing in there
where's marcy okay i don't know what
that
elevator looking thing is
it's a weird crude drawing and there's a
green light
oh god
it feels like a frog is jumping around
in my head oh does it now she seems to
be a part of this house oh good great
good good no matter where you turn you
can feel her anger great good great
ringing her bell was a reminder of her
failures it really did make her mad yeah
i'm picking that up i'm picking that up
yeah i'm picking that up
oh
i'm alive i thought i was dead
good
pick up the old key die die die
dead dead die
all
right okay
oh my god don't you do that to me
you think you could just do that to me
oh you think
oh you think you could just
what about this still a lot how do i
open a good question
it's really dark in here
it's really dark
it's like a lot of dark
is there another door that i haven't
opened yet because i don't remember
if there is or is not one
all right
well
oh
what's happening where are you
where are you
are you above me
oh my god
[Music]
i don't know where she's oh
i don't know where she is
she outside
i don't know
oh my god
oh my god oh my god
i don't know if it's like a thing where
she's hunting me now or what i don't
know what the deal is
i'm 100 unsure
i am very absolutely unsure
and
i don't know where to go i guess i could
go ring her bell
hey you you'd hate that wouldn't you
marcy
mercy oh my god
oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god i have no church oh my god
what happened what happened where am i
where am i where am i where am i fine
i'm fine
well this door exploded open
i can't even ring her bell again i got a
note i scribbled in the dark did she
attack me looks like a little longer
more aggressive how the hell do i leave
there's no sleep there's not supposed to
be a basement here oh good no
good to know
oh good to know
this is great
i love it
let's keep going baby
let's do this
oh [ __ ]
oh
i thought it was going to be an
unlimited thing
maybe they count on that
oh [ __ ]
hi bud
hey how you doing
hey good to see you
door's locked
what a weird key insert yeah what a
weird one
yeah she's a weird one all right
she is definitely a weird one
what is this amazing oh my god why do we
have a maze here
why a maze i don't know what the purpose
of the maze is but here i go getting
lost in the may
what was that
a door with no handle yeah that
henry was working
oh
an odd-shaped key
would this happen to go with in the
odd-shaped circuit box
because that would make sense to me
not that much makes sense in here but
oh
well that's
bright
that's really wait a minute wait a
minute wait wait wait
what happened
she coming after me what's going on
i feel like i've seen this device before
large pulling force required to unlock
safety hatch use pulley handle as given
oh
okay
all right
weird
oh my god oh my god okay all right
that's fine that's fine that's fine did
you just turn off my light do i gotta go
turn it back on you
jerk
you jerk oh you broke it
oh you broke it didn't you
okay
i've had just about enough of you
marcy if that is your real name
listen you think you're all that
i'm here to prove to you that you are
not because i
have a large axe
a very large a axe
shit's big yo
and i know how to use it
oh my
what was that
you'll run that by me again
i think you're close oh hey oh i almost
missed that that was really easy to miss
i wonder if there's another one that i
missed somewhere probably
oh well whatever
i know that i'm probably not gonna get
the completionist ending at this point
but
that's because i'm new to this and if i
find it there's only one left photograph
wise i think but
if i find it i find it if i don't i
don't
oh that's
all right easy enough
not a problem
nothing to say about it but not a
problem
all right
up the stairs i go ah
you
cut that [ __ ] out
cut that [ __ ]
out
[Music]
okay
i gotcha
i got an achievement
i got a cheer of mint
i got an assortment
you think that you can run away from me
the answer is yeah you cannot
okay so i've got one more
i'm putting it up on the board
fits like it belongs and then there's a
place upstairs
[Music]
that has boarded up doors and i've got
an axe so i'm assuming hello
hey who said that
what
who said that
who said that i i don't know i i don't
know
okay
who said that
that door's still not open maybe it
unlocked
okay still locked okay that's that's
good i don't want to go in there anyway
let's try this
oh hi oh my god oh oh [ __ ] okay well
that's
oh
um oh that was not a good idea oh this
was not a good idea i'm gonna read this
note my name is joseph
shippen i wrote this journal in case
something goes wrong i want you to know
that i was here and i probably died here
i came to investigate sweet seven sub
six i did this because marsh shipping is
my mother i only our only son joseph
shippen is 27 years old at the time of
this note wanted to meet her for the
first time and he claimed sweet sevens
have sex it's not real apparently others
were given permission to enter the tweet
with no luck in triggering the cycle or
should i say with luck they did not
trigger the cycle i stand before the
bell this very moment and i'm about to
ring it funny thing is i get this
feeling that i shouldn't ring it i feel
like i rang it before and was sent right
back to try again oh what is happening
wait no no no no no you don't do nothing
no no i've got my eye on you
okay
all right
hopefully i'll snap a few pictures and
we'll see yeah um
okay i don't know oh geez
okay
i don't know what's happening
who
what happened what happened what
happened what happened with you what's
going on
i don't understand i don't know what to
do
oh
wait a minute why are you in the corner
wait you don't want to be in the corner
what are you doing in the corner over
there
okay all right cool
oh oh god oh my god
[Music]
i got [ __ ] slapped
back into eternity
i got bitch-slapped back in time
my name is oh
my god
oh my god so this is where the
crossroads happens
you have a choice
you have a choice to either walk away
or ring the bell
i bet i could i bet i could walk away
right now i bet i could
but i'm not about that
if i am
her son
i want to see this through
the bell for the first time
bella's been wrong for the very first
time
mother
mother oh this shit's getting dark yo
shit's getting dark
ending number one oh no that doesn't
sound like that you know what's strange
i feel like i've done this before that
doesn't sound like the oh come on you
but i didn't get the last photograph i
feel like i've been through this all
seen this all many many times
yeah you know it's funny yeah
it's as though i've made a mistake i've
done something wrong no come on got
something wrong but i'm trying to help
my own mother and because of that
mistake i'm brought back to where it all
began
look you oh come on i already walked
away once i thought this was gonna be
perhaps there is a way to save my mother
to end this curse to end it all
god damn it
god damn that ending's unlocked one of
three
one of three golden bars five six okay
so i
i think i think that
i am also not doing something right
in the long run i think that i'm
not quite perfecting it i'm going back
into it again i want to find
uh
number one i want to find all of the
photographs i wasn't going through it
i'm interested in this game because this
game is
honestly scary
it's rough around very few edges but in
all honesty it's
it's pretty scary and it's an
interesting experience and i haven't had
a you know a kind of horror game that
could sink my teeth into in a while and
i want to see it to the end so i'm going
to do that
oh god
this still spooked me still spooked me
hey bud um
yeah sorry just my brain farted and i
didn't
think about what i was doing what am i
doing i have no idea
whoa what the frick
whoa what just happened
what just happened
hello i got a gold bar
good
i got another i got another gold bar
i didn't do anything
[Music]
oh
okay
all right
i guess because i have over 10 pictures
is that why
it just opened up on its own i didn't
actually do anything so i i
i'm pretty sure that must be what it is
so i'm just gonna go with that and i'm
gonna pretend like everything is hunky
and dory cause everything
hey bud
can you stop actually spooking me again
i've i've been through this before i
know how this goes all right so there
must be more secrets in this basement
that is my guess because it's very easy
to
lose track of things
everything looks the same
everything feels the same oh
what did i tell you
i found all the gold bars
that's what i did
what have you done with your life today
huh and there's that picture okay so i
got all the gold bars so
wait i just i just realized i i got
another one from that other thing so
then i can go get
whatever was in there all right final
gold
oh final gold bar going in right now
so that's inside this was girl's fabric
face
what
pulley handle
perhaps to pull something out all right
i think there was
whoa
what
was that
i think
i think there was something in the
basement
that had to do with pulling
or like a pulley
or something along those lines i can't
remember what it was exactly but i
i'm pretty sure it was like a red brick
it looked like a brick of c4 or
something like that i don't know why i
would be pulling on a brick of c4 unless
i wanted to bring the whole house down
which frankly isn't that bad of an oh
wait we're not in a house we're in a
building yeah this
this makes even less sense than i
originally thought well well well who's
skadoodlin
well you showed up
oh my god there we go
wait that's not a
bomb it sure looks like a bomb
okay oh it's the colors
it's the colors um
red was
three i think green was nine yellow is
seven
so
three one seven nine
oh my god i got it
i nailed it oh my god
i nailed that
i am
incredible and i've got the last picture
oh that's a mannequin that's fine
i got the last picture
well cool i don't know why that was
buried down in a safe
but sure
okay
i've got it
so
what about that
is that gonna if i put that up there can
i go in that other room that says do not
enter in it because i want to go in that
room and i want to go in the do not
enter room i want to go on the do not
don't enter room
get out of my ears
all of marcy memories hopefully she
appreciates this
i don't know what she appreciates
how would i know
i didn't know i was doing this for her
appreciation
i was doing this so i wouldn't die gold
bars photo three
go back to the okay maybe this is a
guide
this might not be right ah i might i
might be wasting a lot of effort here
but i think what that's saying is you go
here after you've got that
she's not here
she's not there anymore she's not there
anymore i'm not going in there i'm not
going in there no way no how i'm not
going in there and then go back to the
photographs
i think it's what it said right
right
right i think that's what it's all about
who
hi
hey marcy
how are you how are you doing
you okay
oh talk sure
how you doing
i'm happy you got this far and reached
me
my true self oh yeah that's a good true
self it's been many years since i have
seen you my son so long that i've
actually forgotten your name oh i'm
truly sorry for that i'm gonna look at
you from this side this this is the side
i'm gonna look at you at i can see
you've come here with the intention to
photograph me to prove to the world that
i exist oh yeah however that's
impossible and you knew that from the
start shall i remind you again suite 776
does not exist anymore it's not been
around for over 30 years wait but i'm
only 27. where you stand right now is
your apartment the apartment that sits
on the land where my home used to be
none of this is real and none of this
happened just like i never killed myself
i was murdered to which during your
upbringing you were seen as the son of a
crazy mother
destined to follow my path the mental
strain and criticism got to you the same
way it got to me don't become me joseph
oh look i remembered your name again
great thanks mom
thank you ciao now come to me and let me
remove you from this place go out there
and live never come back okay
took one picture for memories how about
a selfie either wake up okay
i'm awake now
i think oh there i go
seems more like falling asleep but you
know same difference just two sides of
the same coin
hello ah
i'm awake
my apartment
my beautiful apartment oh wow
it's reasonably sized
wow look at that
oh no shower for me thank you no shower
needed i i never shower actually i find
it to be uh
bad for me
oh there's no number here
okay all right
going to live my life
had a weird nightmare about my dead mom
who was murdered why was she murdered
who murdered her by the way
that's the question i have who murdered
my mother
who did the murdering
of my mom
who whomsed
whomst murdered my mother
homest whom didst
homestead it's funny i never saw myself
as being crazy unless people point it
out i like to think i'm not crazy right
now at least truth is i'll probably come
back home tonight get into bed and
forget forget everything i just
witnessed
is there something wrong with me maybe
it's the pills i'm taking
doctor said they helped my mom so why
wouldn't they help me
there we go
moral of stories nothing ever changes
good god
all right
great
i did it
i got it
i didn't get the easter egg but it's
probably behind that door i don't know
what it is but i don't have time for
more so thank you everybody so much for
watching this was fun this was very
scary i like this a lot i'm glad i was
able to see it through to the end i
don't know what the easter egg is but i
don't have the time or dedication to
find out what it is so if you want to
find out the link for this game is in
the description thank you everybody so
much for watching there's more scary
games and stuff like that linked in the
description as well and a huge playlist
for all of you if you want to see more
of this stuff subscribe ring the bell
but it might make me angry
ringing the bell might remind me of all
of my failures so
ring it
only if you dare
to see what happens after
thanks again
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]